ok ok
où est
oh il ne bouge pas
alors
alors alors
fais
le tour de l'île ici
ouais
ralentis un peu pour que tu puisses tourner à gauche
possible
une fois que je vais travailler
ok merci
maintenant
très lumineux
devant,
qu'est-ce que ça fait
d'avoir un moment
oh  merde désolé
du direct ouais bonjour
ok il y a
trois petites maisons des
maisons oranges en bas
étrangères
ouais ok
viens sous cette ombre hein oh c'est
ça,
notre exposition est devenue très sombre
peut-être pas je ne sais pas ok arrête un
instant
ok bien sûr
ok
je suis désolé,
je suppose que le plan est vraiment là avec une
légère inclinaison vers le bas,
ok
en bas,
c'est ok
ouais, c'est bien,
combien de gars ici,
ok, ok,
ouais,
reviens dans l'autre sens, euh
n'importe quoi, ouais, ouais, d'accord,
alors, d'accord, hein, hein
ok
on dirait qu'un cheval
ressemble à la mi-temps
étranger
alors
bonjour
un peu brumeux ici
un peu un peu de nuage lumineux ouais ouais
étranger
pouvons-nous nous retourner pour que je puisse voir le euh
ouais super
alors
ok
glacier
étranger
non
hmm
salut
étranger
parce que oh la lumière n'est pas, c'est
probablement vraiment génial ce soir puisque
c'est juste
ici
alors sachons juste que tu voles quand nous avons de
très très bonnes lumières
puisque nous restons à l'hôtel pendant
environ deux ou trois jours, d'accord, nous pouvons nous
installer
ici
d'accord, j'y
vais,
oh ouais, c'est dur, je ne travaille pas, c'est un
hélicoptère qui marche,
je bouge juste quelques pogs,
viens un peu autour de
la caméra,
ok, c'est
bien, c'est bien, ouais, tu peux voler normalement maintenant,
vole droit
avec tes pieds normaux,
ça va  pour être assez soigné, quand est-ce qu'on arrive à
descendre, passe un de ces gros rochers
ici, quelques-uns de ces rochers
oh ouais,
je suis euh plus de deux mille ici pas de
problème,
il y a de très gros rochers ici,
d'accord,
va là où se trouve le  l'eau claire est pour que
tu puisses voir un reflet ouais ça
va être vraiment cool
c'est
une autre très grosse boule de glace n'est-ce pas mais il
y a un reflet ouais le reflet
arrive
hong kong c'est
drôle parce qu'avec l'oeil tu peux
vraiment voir le reflet mais sur  la
caméra tu sais ouais eh bien nous le verrons
dans une minute quand nous arriverons à l'endroit clair
ouais ok désolé sceau au revoir bonjour au
revoir la
dernière fois que j'ai vu un plan comme celui-là, c'était en
Nouvelle-Zélande
droit étranger
ok arrête l'enregistrement s'il te plaît
2000 s'il vous plaît